voilà comme ça les chapeaux de se salir
on tend
à je vous attendais bonjour le facteur
va m'apporter de grands cartons plein
chapeau j'ai décidé de faire une
exposition de chapeau pour les enfants
lire toutes sortes de chapeaux c'est une
bonne idée mais ce pas
voilà le facteur qui arrive bonjour
facteur bonjour mademoiselle julie
alors vous les avez mis chaque année
voilà mais je vais tout de suite vous
cherchez le dernier colis à ce n'est pas
que ce soit vraiment lourd mais pour sûr
c'est encombrant ou je voulais pas cela
la bon pour autant dé facteurs je crois
que dans l'autre coin ça sera plus
pratique ah bon alors
là voilà écoutez facteur à la réflexion
je pense que sur le tabouret ça serait
encore mieux comme ça je pourrais tous
les étals et
dites moi vous vous n'allez pas changer
la vie vous vous êtes sur moi ne vous
moquez pas de moi facteurs je sais que
je suis de nature est vif et désordonnée
mais là c'est l'impatience de voir mes
chapeaux je vous comprends bon bah
écoutez à tout à l'heure je vais tout de
suite vous cherchez le dernier col
tout à l'heure j'ai dit oui oui
son joli à mes chapeaux
c'était vraiment qu
en est-il
celui là regarde parce que c'est
mon billet 15 millions julie et côté
taha mais moi aussi je suis qu'au caire
c'est un défaut qui se pa bon alors je
ne suis pas coquet ou d'ailleurs c'est
un défi très féminin
ah bon les hommes ne sont jamais coquet
même même monsieur du stade dynamo il ya
des exceptions mais imagine tu es un
homme se mettant un chapeau si ridicule
sur la tête
voilà sûrement pas
allons voir julie mais passe alors sur
ce que nous avons dit elle serait
furieuse par tainmont pas
bon
bonjour julie au salut alors comment
vont me trouver
qu'est ce que tu as tu ne peux plus
parler aux jeunes malades oh oui oh
kazim et des quelque chose mais tu m'as
demandé de ne pas prononcer un mot
pourquoi pas un amour il ne vous prends
soin ne voulait pas que je te répète ce
qu'il m'a dit tu es si mais qu'est ce
que tu lui as dit eh bien il a dit que
tu étais très coquette comme toutes les
femmes
ah bon tu prétends que les hommes ne
sont pas cotées
aux états unis je n'ai pas été long owen
on m'a dit bonjour françois re bonjour
qu'un juge militaire a
je comprends vous êtes venus admirer les
chapeaux à a poursuivi son joli
sens plutôt venu me dire que seules les
femmes étaient assez coquette pour
porter des chapeaux originaux sois
gentil ça pas du tout même qu'un deuil
en moi moi je l'aimais bien ma casquette
un bien sur factor avec moi elle est
très jolie votre carnet c'est quand même
une coiffure sobre qui est surtout utile
poursuit et sans ma casquette
j'attrapais des coups de soleil
bon alors il faut que je m'enlève j'ai
jemma tournée a continué à bientôt mes
amis bon convoi américain d'un facteur
françois prétend que seules les femmes
sont coquettes et que les hommes ne se
déguise jamais alors ça m'a donné l'idée
d'un jeu je vais vous montrer toutes
sortes de chapeaux et vous allez me dire
qu'ils les portent ou qui les portaient
parce que certains sont d'époque
d'accord
de rechercher aussi allégée du premier
chapeau
magnifique celui ci est un fait ça alors
comment s'appelle ce château
cry for days
et bien c'est un chapeau de grenadiers
de la gamme de napoléon en réalité il
manque une pièce i'm aucun plus mais sur
le côté et ça pourrait aussi être un
chapeau de horgues ward connaissez les
orges doit repenser la garde de la reine
en angleterre à regarder la mer tient
très ému et heureux ouais on dirait une
batte plein de poils
un autre chapeau je les loue un
gpo voilà
un garde oui c'est un casque de garde
qu'elle garde
si le casque de la garde républicaine à
cheval de paris voyez là y'a les
cuissots de la ville de paris
je venais patrick sergeant ces lourds
annoncés pour les lourdes en voilà en
quarts à paris les bogies si
c'est pas un chaque coup c'est un
chapeau mais cet achat qui s'appelle un
képi comme didier très bien christelle
de général ils ont tous de vie mais là
ce avait deviné oui moi je sais pas ce
qu'on nous qui le timbre postal il est
moniteur
encore pour colas bien sûr très bien
celui là
effectivement tout le monde connaît
ouais et c'est également et mémoires
comme le képi du général tient
jean-françois celui là non
non non non c'est porte pas dans ce sens
là par la peau les os il se porte comme
ça napoléon c'était dans ce sens là
qu'ils n'avaient pas les petits poils
comme ça au dessus quel est ce jeu
plumes et des broderies
comme ça moi c'est ce que je vise oui à
l'état un chapeau d'académiciens voilà
qu'il veut de la collision
[Musique]
celui là c'est beau car ils ont beaucoup
moins coloré celui-ci plus sévères ne
vous rappelle rien qu'est ce que c'est
et procès police et une toque une toque
de juge tiens on va voir si ça doit
christelle
et séduit la télé québécoise et d'ici là
non oui ça c'est un chapeau aux mains
avec le poteau je me poserai célèbre
kristen c'est lui là
à nous nous penchons ça ressemble le
cobaye mais ça n'est pas
c'est un chapeau espagnol a sombré ronde
et ça ça sert elle fixe et où elle
rejetée en arrière pour qu'ils tiennent
à stéphanie très bien et celui là
ça c'est très habillée qu'est ce que
c'est
c'est à hautefort halle c'est un chapeau
il va avec un habit de cérémonie
l'évidence
est approuvé de 16 après ça s'appelle
une mitre c'est une mitre d'évêque c'est
magnifique regardez les becs
extraordinaire voilà enfin facile
souligné cuisinier et ça s'appelle une
toque
une toque de cuisinier
torture car j'aime qui a déjà deux d'oka
et les derniers
maillons il ressemble aussi à celui de
napoléon c'est le bicorne de napoléon
une reproduction évidemment il est porté
aussi par les gendarmes
thurella autres julie non c'est terminé
c'est alors que mon exposition de
chapeau elle était val c'était vraiment
et françois ce que tu pense toujours que
seules les femmes portent des chapeaux
évidemment juge j avais pas songé aux
uniformes mais on reconnaît que les
hommes portent de moins en moins ce
genre de coiffure
oui bien sûr mais les femmes non plus ne
les porte pas regarde les chapeaux que
j'avais tout à l'heure ne sont pas
portés par les femmes à l'heure actuelle
sur le mode et c'est vrai je dis tu as
raison mais alors qui est le plus de
coke et des deux c'est moi au
casimir
moi j'ai vraiment une tête à chapeaux
[Musique]
bonjour je lis à lui quasiment pas vu
mes nouveaux jouets ouais alors alors
alors comme on les trouve sur un très
bon très bon dis moi que fait françois
là bas avec les enfants y jouent au jeu
des mimes au jeu les mines au formidable
tu sais ces mots c'est mon jeu favori ah
oui une belle une deux puis deux mecs
qu'est ce que tu fais casimir pas des
exercices d'assouplissement toit souple
y croit mais mes assouplir mes muscles
un grand mime doit toujours avoir les
muscles très souple une de bon je suis
prêt j'y vais résumer où tu appelles
regarder mais jouer
bon alors ce comprend pas
personne ne s'intéresse à mes nouveaux
jouets mécaniques les enfants
avec moi
[Musique]
voir déjà riche de julie avons défendu
hier
on fait vraiment très beau
n'est ce pas quel est celui qui préfère
bon c'est typique dans les trompes ou
spread rôle
d'annie des bulles émettant marché oui
tu sais tout à l'heure j'étais
tranquille parce que personne ne
s'intéressait à mes jouets alors j'ai
réfléchi et je me suis dit que l'intérêt
des mécaniques c'était d'être mécanique
oui enfin alors vraiment julie pour
enfants tu as des idées elles sont
géniales ne te mokrane moi c'est très
sérieux alors je les ai faits marché est
maintenant toujours s'y intéresse je
suis sûr que j'en veux beaucoup
julie tu m'avais une idée formidable que
je vais gagner beaucoup d'argent j'ai
justement besoin de claudie francs pour
renouveler ma provision de gloubiboulga
ses 28 ans donc désigné
ça c'est une surprise à
là encore une dernière
la
hat ça y est c'est parfait bon bah ça y
est allé demander des bougies venez
acheter des belles bougies
d'amender les belles bougies bon allez
voir mes bougies
casimir qu'est ce que tu fais là je mets
pour une bête question c'est vraiment
une mais deux questions 1 il paraît
évident que ce soit en train de vendre
des bougies oui mais je m'en suis aperçu
figure toi seulement pourquoi les as-tu
allumé mais pour montrer comment il
marche peux tu ne vas pas pouvoir les
vendre
et pourquoi tu me disais le contraire
tout à l'heure enfin enfin casimir ça
n'a aucun rapport
quand je fais marcher mes jouets
mécaniques je les ai pas si tu fais
brûler t bougies elles ne pourront plus
servir à rien mais c'est pourtant le
seul moyen pour montrer aux acheteurs si
elles marchent bien ou pas mais pas des
bougies
ah bon alors tu crois que je ne vais pas
réussir à gagner les 10 francs dont j'ai
besoin pour mon gloubiboulga a sûrement
pas au boycott je vais essayer quand
même un laisse-moi à lait d'amande elle
est belle bougie
acheter des bougies
[Musique]
bodji demandé mais
bogies
vous voulez des bougies non elles sont
pas chères jean-marc non au
bourget valais le résultat casimir là où
les bougies et tu n'as rien vendu tu as
raison jolie j'aurais vraiment pas dû
faire une démonstration
pour ma très chère julie bonjour mais c
est stable que se passe-t-il avec ce bon
casimir rien rien du tout monsieur du
snow balibar là-bas si j'y suis donc
fait voir quelle merveille
auquel poésie de couleur quelle matière
à j'aimerais bien connaître l'artiste
génial que créer une oeuvre aussi
supprime que celle là ça vous plaira
infiniment et bien ça c'est à vendre
merveilleux sens france en vain non 110
a
ajouté c'est un peu cher et bien il faut
100 francs pour le génial artiste c'est
à dire moi est différent pour ma réserve
de gloubiboulga
[Musique]